mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
wissen steam vertrieben
irgendwann schlägt die letzte stunde für
jeden
unausweichlich der tod ist etwas
ungeheuerliches unsere rückkehr ist
nichts eine der größten zumutungen die
das leben uns auferlegt ob es an
jenseits gibt oder nicht die endlichkeit
fordert uns heraus die haben keine angst
vor dem tod aber
vor der ster bereich
auf spurensuche nach einer neuen kultur
des abschieds was bleibt wenn wir
sterben
[Musik]
ja wir denken heute über den tod nach
über sterben mit und ohne gott ob es
tust gibt auch für jene die nicht
glauben können oder wollen und welche
rolle dabei der humor spielt ja wir alle
haben wohl mit corona einem bewusst
wertungs prozess durchgemacht die eigene
sterblichkeit lässt sich nicht mehr ganz
so einfach verdrängen glaubt man den
östlichen philosophien ist das ganz
genau das richtige rezept das leben
bewusst zu genießen
[Musik]
ja der tod und wir willkommen auf dem
kulturplatz heute aus dem kunstmuseum
basel
[Musik]
ja was spendet uns trost angesichts des
todes eine quelle ist ganz bestimmt die
literatur die poesie die sprache welche
worte finden wir angesichts des todes
von geliebten menschen dazu haben wir
zwei unterschiedliche frauen befragt
es gibt keine formel nur das gelingen
eine trauerrede und sicher gibt es sie
auch nicht die perfekte trauerrede aber
wenn meine tochter sagt sie hatte das
gefühl dass ihr vater bei der
abschiedsfeier dabei gewesen sei und sie
habe dies als tröstlich empfunden oder
wenn mich ein trauer ganz hinterher
fragt ob ich den gestorbenen gekannt
hätte dann weiß ich dass ich mit meinen
worten zumindest einige der zu hörenden
erreicht habe
was bleibt wenn wir sterben diese frage
treibt die journalistin und autorin luis
brown um als ihre eltern sterben sucht
sie einen weg aus der trauer und wird
trauerrednerin
aber für meine eltern gestorben der tod
nicht zu entnehmen und jetzt ist ein
ganz wichtiger teil davon und das ist
auch in ordnung so weil durch dieses
bewusstsein dass mein leben irgendwie
endlich ist durch diese tägliche
konfrontation mit tod und trauer lebe
ich auch anders ich lebe intensiver
glaube ich es ist so als ob das leben
ein bisschen so eine andere dimension
bekommen hat eine andere tiefe
ihre erfahrungen als trauerrednerin hat
sie in einem buch niedergeschrieben
darin schreibt sie von ihrem umgang mit
dem tod ihrer eltern und sie berichtet
von den vielen gesprächen mit den
angehörigen von verstorbenen
es ist ja oft so dass sind trauer
gespräch erst mal die bilder vom ende
eines lebens sehr im vordergrund stehen
na ja die bilder von der krankheit von
dem sterben und die sind so präsent und
deswegen ist es so schön wenn man bei
der trauerfeier die anderen bilder
hervor holte die vom ganzen leben quasi
und tiefs und vorne im raum stehen und
es sind ja auch gerade so diese kleinen
details die kleine bilder aus dem leben
die einen menschen wie das richtig
lebendig werden lassen
sie war bestimmend und ordnungsliebend
konsequent wenn es um die hausaufgaben
der kinder ging aber sonntags morgens
war kuscheln mit den kindern im bett
pflicht
die arbeit in der werft an den großen
schiffen war sein traum die kinder nahm
er mit in den hafen zu den schiffstaufen
damit sie die großen schiffe sehen
konnten wenn er abends nach hause kam
hatte er zufällig brutto übrig auf diese
hasen brote haben sich die kinder immer
gefreut
[Musik]
anger und lilo teilten sich über 20
jahre den kleingarten anlass für eine
stunde in ihrem buch lilo hielt es keine
fünf minuten auf der liga aus als lilo
starb war es im garten einfach nicht
mehr dasselbe
das war halt ein ganz großer wunsch
schon mehr dass vielleicht jemand das
liest der vielleicht gerade trauer dass
ich vielleicht hineinführt oder
vielleicht nicht versteht was gerade mit
sich passiert das vielleicht durch
dieses buch ja sich ein klein wenig
weniger allein führt in diesem moment
trost durch sprache sucht auch ein
außergewöhnliches projekt in zürich hier
auf dem friedhof northeim findet einmal
im jahr ein sammelbegriff für einsam
verstorbene menschen statt
menschen die zum zeitpunkt des todes
keine angehörigen mehr hatten während
die urnen in die erde gelassen werden
lesen dichterinnen und dichter jeweils
ein gedicht vor dass sie für die
einsamen verstorbenen geschrieben haben
die autorin melanie cut ist initiant in
das projekt und
[Musik]
das sind alles begleit gaben der jeweils
einzeln verstorbene mensch wo es ihm
letzte werk mit 1 samstag die
dichterinnen vom dienst wie sie sich
nennen gehen vor dem begräbnis an den
ort wo die verstorbene person gelebt hat
reden mit nachbarn und holen sich so
inspiration für das gedicht
ein passagier
die vorstadt streift dich je nach
fahrtrichtung kann der linken oder
rechten schulter
[Musik]
klingt im vorbeigehen aus einem
kopfhörer
gepuderte stadtteile ziehen vorbei
das gleiche licht weiter draußen
die haltestellen anzeige steht still mit
einem herz mit einem atem
auf einer webseite werden die gedichte
für die einsamen verstorbenen gesammelt
hier kann jeder leser und jede leserin
zeuge dieses angedenken sein
ein virtuelles denkmal das mit poesie
der einsamkeit entgegentritt einsamkeit
ist das sozialpolitische fragen
als gesellschaft nicht leisten das lied
jeder form
unsere miete somit abschlüsse und für
mich das ergebe
sich auch in der politische sinn
berichtet dass das wird das einfach
verstauen
der tod kennt keine gerechtigkeit das
ist eine erkenntnis die auch luis brown
in ihrer langjährige arbeit als
trauerrednerin gelernt hat doch wie löst
man los wenn das leid das einzige ist
was einem bleibt wie akzeptiert man
einen unerwarteten einen zu frühen tod
wenn ich am anfang einer trauerfeier
vorne stehe man hat dieser wonach dieser
verzweiflung spüre das ist wirklich fies
oder brandneue wie von der kalte band
aber wenn ich dann anfange zu erzählen
wenn nicht eine diese vielen geschichten
zusammen bringen diese fragmente und
eine ganze geschichte erzähle dann spürt
man unsere intensität um eine wärme
entsteht zu einem raum das unheimlich
schön zu sehen und wiesen kleines licht
das von den trauergästen irgendwie
angeht und zusätzlich tragen sie dann
immer weiter mit sich wenn sie die
kapelle verlassen wir menschen sind dem
tod also nicht ganz hilflos ausgeliefert
ein mächtiges werkzeug des trostes
bleibt uns die sprache
[Musik]
die kunst setzte sich schon immer
intensiv mit dem tod auseinander hier
der leichnam christi von hans holbein
dem jüngeren unter diesem starken bild
treffe ich franz josef wetz wir stehen
hier vor dem toten christus herz was
löst dieses bild in ihnen aus also ich
finde das bild zutiefst provokant und
zweideutig zum einen steht es für die
christliche hoffnung der auferstehung es
ist praktisch der karfreitag hinter sich
gebracht auf der anderen seite wirkt
dieser tote christus so als ob er die
auferstehung verschlafen hätte und
wollte dem betrachter der es ansieht
sagen guten tag bitte aber lassen sie
mich in ruhe und lassen sie mich hier in
ruhe liegen das bild wirkt ja nicht so
als wäre es zwei tage alt der tote
christus sondern er wäre schon mehrere
tage alt und hätte wirklich diese
auferstehung verpasst also auch für die
idee dass es möglicherweise mit der
auferstehung nichts ist eine
antwort sie bekennen sich ein atheist zu
sein haben dieses buch geschrieben tod
ohne gott als was ist es zu verstehen
eine trost trifft eben gerade für die
atheisten ja es ist eine aufklärung und
schriftführer humanistische atheisten
die dazu neigen den tod zu
bagatellisieren
aus der angst dass menschen wenn sie den
tod ernst nehmen zu schnell in die fänge
der religion gerieten aber das ist
natürlich eine verkürzung des problems
der tod ist etwas ungeheuerliches
unsere rückkehr ins nichts eine der
größten zumutungen die das leben uns
auferlegt immerhin bedeutet der tod so
viel wie der verlust der größtmögliche
verlust aller lebens güter des lebens
selbst dass man damit nicht ohne
weiteres fertig wird steht versteht sich
meines aus meiner sicht von selbst
[Musik]
ja herr wetzel schreiben milliarden von
menschen glauben an einen gott und
milliarden menschen ihren bei allem
respekt das klingt etwas anmaßend ja das
ist mir sehr bewusst dass ihn sehr
anmaßend sogar aber es ist da nicht viel
anmaßen dazu glauben dass unsere wegen
die naturgesetze aufgehoben werden dass
in diesem westlichen universum alles zu
werden und vergehen verurteilt ist
außerdem menschen diesem kleinen
lebewesen auf dem kleinen planeten dass
seinetwegen alles durchbrochen ist was
sonst ein naturgesetzen gilt das klingt
doch aus meiner sicht viel anmaßender
geradezu unverschämt und für mich ist es
auch geradezu lächerlich zu denken dass
wir der wirklichkeit was sie in letzer
beziehung auch immer ist ewig zur last
fallen wollen aber was kann man daran
falsch sein trost zu finden in der
religion oder in der spiritualität für
etwas was man nicht erklären kann welche
quelle des trostes hat wagen wenn ihm
der religiöse zuspruch fehlt da gibt es
natürlich die musik da gibt es viele
philosophische weisheiten da gibt es
allerlei trost mittel vor allem das
gespräch das miteinander schweigen mit
freunden den beschwerlichen alltag der
welt das genügt den letzter beziehung
nicht wenn eine diesen tröstungen
angemessene grundhaltung fehlt erst wenn
der mensch der bereit ist seine eigene
stellung in der welt zu relativieren
wenn wir bereit sind zu sagen ich bin
ein vergängliches stück lebewesen in
dieser unermesslichen welt also wenn wir
eine was ich gerne kosmische
bescheidenheit kultivieren mich zurück
stelle ins große ganze und zurücknehmen
kann dann kann eine gewisse
tröstung eine gewisse demut entstehen
die mich auch mit der eigenen
vergänglichkeit aussehen lässt ist das
dann das resultat eines traurigen
naturalisten was jetzt gerade
beschreiben sie nennen sich ja einen
traurigen naturalisten trauriger
naturalismus das bringt samuel beckett
noch besser auf den begriff wenn er sagt
gott über gott der lump er existiert
nicht wir hätten ihn so nötig aber er
fehlt uns trauriger naturalismus heißt
ich bin von dem religiösen emotional
angesprochen aber verstandes mäßig
überhaupt nicht überzeugt von dem
eigenen naturalistischen stand tun
wonach mit dem tod alles zu ende ist das
finde ich verstandes mäßig absolut
überzeugend aber emotional überhaupt
nicht ansprechen es ist ja eigentlich
einfacher zu glauben da muss man sich
auch diese fragen nicht stellen lernen
sie lieber gläubig
ja man wäre lieber gläubig aber der
abwesende gott ist mit dem stärksten
argument seiner existenziellen benötigen
nicht einfach vorhanden dann wenn das
nicht da ist dann ist es nicht da und in
diese situation habe ich ja hinein
philosophiert ja ob harald naegeli an
ein leben nach dem tod glaubt wir wissen
es nicht was wir hingegen wissen ist
hart nägeli der legendäre sprayer von
zürich setzt sich schon seit langen
jahren mit dem tod auseinander auch mit
dem eigenen für einen dokumentarfilm
lässt dass ich tief in die seele blicken
und plötzlich sind sie wieder da die
vertrauten strichfiguren an den
hausmauern von zürich
die korona pandemie hat den sprayer von
zürich zurück gebracht
lizenznehmer oder der totentanz ist
meine letzte
antworten
in meinem leben und
seine utopie die komplette freiheit der
kunst harald nagel die lebt sie bis ins
hohe alter wie der vielschichtige
dokumentarfilm zeigt gegen ende seines
schaffens krebskrank kann er nicht mehr
draußen spray zeichnet aber immer noch
mein kopf ist
dies nur wunderbar
aber die zeit ist abgelaufen
noch nicht ganz
tempi passati
deshalb keinen sinn zu lamentieren ich
habe mich zb bei exit angemeldet wenn
ich zu viele schmerzen habe da machen
schluss ich will entscheiden nicht an
der film begleitet ihn bei seinem
letzten herzensprojekt dem totentanz im
zürcher grossmünster
der entstehungsprozess noch einmal nah
die versus zürich der tod des im rahmen
halten sich
vor mir manche wand vor der
illuminierten
man studiert es wird gestorben
das ist die konzeption sieht die beide
zum zuspieler aber der hertie haben wir
ja nur die weite teil zu gewissen markus
kg damals kantonaler baudirektor von der
svp auch sein versuch nagele in einen
behördlichen rahmen zu sperren scheitert
[Musik]
abgemacht und zwar schriftlich und
mündlich mit handschlag dass er der
vorgänger radius liegt darüber spreche
man das trainerteam romina sogar mit
handschlag besiegelt da haben wir das
gesprochen leider hat das die sprache
woche und da bin ich mit
magali bleibt eben nadal
die provokation ist immer dabei auch bei
seiner unvollendeten letzten arbeit und
doch findet sich mit gutem willen ein
verstecktes waffenstillstandsangebot
für
das ist
also versöhnung gar wohl kaum
sein widerstand gegen die normen damals
in den 1970 er und 80 er jahren für das
bürgerliche zürich eine provokation
gejagt von der polizei wegen
sachbeschädigung verurteilt und ins
gefängnis gesteckt
so etwas wie rehabilitiert spät zwar
aber immerhin
2020 ehrt in zürich mit den städtischen
großen kunstpreis
diesen weiten bürger spart der
dokumentarfilm und schaut dabei ganz
tief ins innere des menschen harald
nagel
da habe ich mich selber gezeichnet
da habe ich diese lachfalten gemacht
die kunst ist dass man ihn tot lächelt
ich habe keine angst vor dem tod aber
vor der ster bereich
[Musik]
jetzt haben wir halt nägeli gehört er
sagt er habe keine angst vor dem tod
aber vor dieser sterbe reihe ist das
jetzt klassischer galgenhumor das sagt
man heute immer dass man keine angst vor
dem tod hat du angst vor dem sterben vor
der apparatemedizin ich habe zweifel an
dieser these ich finde die
nachvollziehbar wenn die lebensqualität
gering und die lebensqualität ist da
kann ich gut nachvollziehen dass man aus
dem leben scheiden möchte wenn man aber
in der mitte des lebens steht dann ist
sicherlich die rede von der nicht
vorhandenen todesangst falsch dort halte
ich es für eine gedankenlose kurse für
leichtsinnige prahlerei ist es nicht so
gedacht dass man sich denkt beim sterben
da kommen die schmerzen da kommt das
ganz große kino was man sich so
vorstellen wenn ich tot bin dann spiele
ich ja nicht mehr so ist es doch gedacht
ja können sie dem es unter diesen titel
zu stimmen ja da kann ich zustimmen aber
das problem ist ja nicht das nicht sein
sondern das abtauchen ins nichts das
macht den menschen ja deshalb eben angst
weil sie ja weil es eine natürliche
anhänglichkeit ans leben gibt und damit
ist auch eine todesangst verbunden die
die vorsicht vor das war chris setzt und
der gefahrenabwehr dient also die
todesangst etwas durchaus sinnvoll wenn
man aber war hoch betagt ist und die
lebensqualität wirklich geringer wird
und die lebensqualität wenn die
situation ausweglos wird dann ist eine
einwilligung in das eigene ende durchaus
nachvollziehbar aber wenn jemand in der
mitte des lebens jugendliche so reden
dann nehme ich es ihnen eben nicht ab
und halte es für einen duncan lose pose
humor kann auf jeden fall trost spenden
könnte man sagen das lachen ist das
beten der ungläubigen ja das ist
vielleicht etwas zu hoch gegriffen aber
humor es natürlich immer gut humor wird
ja definiert dass man in einer
beschwerlichen situation trotzdem lachen
kann also dass trotzdem ist entscheidend
es gibt eben einen großen sprach humor
im zusammenhang mit dem tod also der tod
der all der berufsgruppen den elektriker
trifft der schlag der der der
straßenkehrer der kehrten die wieder das
versteht dann auch einen grabstein unter
umständen der koch gibt den löffel ab
und und der gärtner bei stars also da
gibt es den sprachrohr und viele andere
um wertvolle situation aber wenn es denn
wirklich dann ernst wird dann bleibt
dann doch oftmals den menschen das
lachen im hals stecken sie haben sich
viele orte angeguckt wo es dann ernst
wird sterbehospiz mit und ohne gott so
zu sagen wo stirbt es dich dann am
besten was ist ihre bilanz diese ziehen
am besten stirbt das sich in der nacht
im schlaf ich glaube da können wir uns
wirklich alle einigen darauf ganz
herzlichen dank für dieses gespräch
franzose fällt
ja was wäre der film ohne den tod ob
action films thriller oder komödie im
film wird gestorben was das zeug hält
dem sterben zuzuschauen das scheint ein
menschliches bedürfnis zu sein über den
tod zu lachen allerdings auch
der holprige weg zur ewigen ruhe in der
slapstick-komödie würdelos
im abenteuerfilm mit indiana jones
kampflos
an den stephen kings satire ein schocker
dieser effekt funktioniert übrigens in
welchem job
[Applaus]
bei den coen-brüdern dagegen genügt die
falsche windrichtung
der mensch scheidet dahin und wir lachen
dabei dahinter steckt mehr als makabrer
spaß
filmwissenschaftler marius kuhn sagt
lustige filme über den tod meinen
eigentlich das leben in der komödie gott
sehr allgemein eigentlich um
konfrontation mit gesellschaftlicher
konventionen oder gesellschaftliche
normen und dadurch sehr sehr oft um die
angst und sehschwache als mensch und
hund natürlich der tod sehr schnelles
spiel
[Musik]
satire stoffe
dort anders thematisieren und war mit
dem tabu manchmal öffnet cover mehr so
scheinlich ignoriert oder probieren zu
drängen legendär der rabenschwarzer
humor der britischen satire truppe monty
python motto der tod ist unverschämt wir
sind unverschämter britische polens zum
schießen komisch
[Musik]
helden colt und religiöse gefühle die
lieblings zielscheiben von mantey
prallten weswegen dieser film in einigen
ländern verboten wurde
[Musik]
ich glaube die frage nach dem guten
geschmack habe grenzen von geschmack hat
ja sehr stark mit gesellschaftlichen
normen store und dir den sie komplett
brief oder konfrontiert die normen ganz
stark
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
ewig leben oder sterben fragt sich was
schlimmer ist hollywoods antwort darauf
geben meryl streep und cody horn in der
tod steht ihr gut
eine fortschreibung des jugend- und
schönheitswahn bis zum bitteren ende
meryl streep hat sich sehr schön gesagt
wo sie an und hat für sie ist das
eigentlich fast ein dokumentarfilm
durchschnittlich erneut die satirisch
spitze dagegen dass der film überhaupt
nicht überdreht ist sondern als
realistisches bild von hollywood weiter
erhöht
das totenreich als spielwiese des humors
funktioniert selbst im kinderfilm in
coco wird der kleine mexikanische junge
miguel am feiertag für die toten in viel
salz befördert so witzig und rührend
dass der film mit dem oscar
ausgezeichnet wurde
der tod und uns alle ein
lachen wir darüber
solange wir noch können
[Musik]
eine junge aargauer konzept designerin
setzt sich mit dem tod zu zeiten von
corona auseinander und das tut sie mit
einem podcast mein kollege nino gadient
von sf kultur auf instagram hat sie
getroffen
endlich sein so heiße podcast foto
viviana leiter leonhard sicher junge
podcast drin und beschäftigt sich mit
dem tod das erste mal wohin der tod im
himmel aber so richtig gespürt habe
schon einige stolpersteine plötzlich
gemerkt durch das gefühl vor der
endlichkeit
dennis aufgegangen mit dem alltag mit
dem leben ist es schlimm oder ist es gar
kurz dass der tod eigentlich nie so
richtig nie selber bewusst ist auf das
noch die antwort da vor der todes
spezialisten
[Musik]
das expertin
laut studie relativ bunt und fröhlich
für endlichkeit expertin designerin hat
sich schon studium intensiv mit dem tod
beschäftigt und auch sport ist interesse
am thema bleibe in ihrem podcast wie sie
ja anderer art direkter zugang zum
botschafter ganze live der balance
verpflichtet erzählt sie mir nur
flüchtig theologie und große und über
not denker sondern mehr alle
unverkrampft und ohne angst darum hat
sie als kunst festival hallo tod mit
begründet dass ich dieses ziel mit dem
podcast
zum
duschen an der kunsthochschule studiert
designerin machst du tot jetzt einfach
dran die
bessere form sondern es ist für musik
business ist vorm runde
und der tod
ersten sich als unsichtbar und wenn dann
hätte meistens attraktiver geworden und
die wünsche stürmers im
breitformat betrag auf dem motto tut
jedem zugang also was wenn es konkret
das ist ästhetisch urne geht wo die
aussprechen widerspricht jeder
eigentlich suchen aber zunächst einmal
bleibt was auf dem grabstein steht weiß
und was für den text film geradezu
graffy unglaublich wichtig so visuelle
erscheinungsbild
es gibt eine bestattungsform wo kann ich
mir ihnen gossau kleid wird und du
willst endlich wieder einmal bestimmte
ort bestattet aber ist so etwas noch ein
paar noch eine prämie körper wird gott
hilf in
der bahn kann
krass
ist genau das passiert was ich mit
passiert wenn man über den tod reden man
wird das gefühl noch so ganz intensiv
leben
einigkeit
was man nicht sagen
[Musik]
ja ein langes gutes leben leben und dann
zu frieden sterben wer wünscht sich das
nicht und wünschen daran glaube ich kann
durchaus helfen
wie auch gute gesellschaft helfen kann
und um eine solche kümmern wir uns
nächsten mittwoch nämlich um die familie
und jetzt geht's gleich weiter bei sf 1
mit der sternstunde philosophie und ganz
passend mit einem blick ins jenseits
kommen sie quicklebendig durch die woche
[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur des
westens
[Applaus]